combien de temps faut-il pour faire 10
km à Montréal en moyenne réponse 18
minutes et 50 secondes ce qui place la
métropole aux 80e rang mondial selon ce
rapport de l'entreprise TomTom qui
fabrique des GPS la première place la
moins enviable c'est Londres qui
l'occupe il faut presque deux fois plus
de temps pour parcourir la même distance
et au Canada Montréal Toronto Winnipeg
ou Vancouver à votre avis où est-ce que
c'est le plus lent de se déplacer de
faire 10 km en voiture à Montréal
Montréal
ici à Montréal en fait Toronto et
Vancouver classé 30 et 31ème au monde ce
partage le premier rang canadien avec 22
minutes 30 et ça roule aussi moins vite
à Winnipeg à Montréal il faut 20
secondes de plus dans la capitale du
Manitoba pour faire 10 km c'est un sujet
qui est difficile de d'arriver avec les
perceptions parce que on a quand on fait
pisser normal quand on est poignet
dedans c'est c'est notre vie on perd
notre temps et le moment où l'on perd le
plus de temps c'est vers la fin de la
semaine c'est en tout cas ce que montre
les données de ce rapport leurs deux
pointe la plus difficile c'est le jeudi
entre 15h et 18h ici vous voyez il faut
27 minutes 30 c'est 10 minutes de plus
que la moyenne pour parcourir 10 km et
on propose cet exercice si vous décidez
de ne télétravailler par exemple que le
jeudi vous allez gagner à l'année 38
heures de temps libre et 143 dollars
d'économisés en un an bon affaire merci
mon employeur mais oui pourquoi pas tant
mieux pour ceux qui peuvent se le
permettre je pense que c'est bien
d'éviter le trafic moi j'aimerais bien
mais je peux pas tout infirmière pas
très loin derrière Londres dans le
classement Paris est à la 11e place le
paradoxe c'est que ces deux villes
offrent un bon service de transport en
commun il y a toujours une demande de
déplacement en automobile dans cette
ville-là et comme on en a profité que on
arrivait déplacé de la demande de Paris
est devenu une façon assez surprenante
personnellement une un symbole de du
vélo dans le monde entier c'est
extrêmement récent et c'est comme s'ils
avaient capitalisé et quand on fait ça
bah on prend de l'espace sur les autres
l'autre enseignement de ce rapport c'est
la place qu'occupe la ville de Québec
ville canadienne la plus fluide du
classement à la 295e place il faut
seulement 12 minutes en moyenne pour
faire 10 km comme nous le confirme cette
résidence de passage à Montréal ça très
bien qui est du trafic pas de trafic
aller travailler c'est en 10 15 minutes
sur la même route donc ça dit que c'est
peut-être pas un énorme problème
effectivement les enjeux de congestion à
Québec ce genre de données en plus
d'offrir un peu de recul sur notre
réalité est aussi un outil pour les
décideurs modifier les infrastructures
existantes des incitatives que ce soit
de changer de mode que ce soit de
changer de façon de travailler et en
attendant des changements d'habitudes
reste la routine des embouteillages donc
là je repars sur la réussite j'ai une
demi-heure de route encore pour 15 km
ici Mathieu pros Radio-Canada MONT